le mot économie est souvent utilisé pour
parler de la richesse du pib de la
croissance de la bourse de l'argent mais
ce mot veut dire bien plus dans le réel
comme sur le plan théorique et le
chercheur alain deneault publie une
série de livres qui ont pour but
justement de restaurer les différentes
significations du mot économie
il est dans nos studios de bathurst au
nouveau brunswick ce soir années de nos
bons soirs lancement vous êtes
professeur maintenant de philosophie à
l'université de moncton correspondant
canadien aussi du collège international
de philosophie en france
dites-nous vous votre objectif en
quelque sorte en publiant cette série de
livres sur l'économie de la nature
l'économie de la foi notamment
c'est ici c'est dans l'optique du projet
là de revoir ce mont économies qu'on a
tendance à restreindre à une série d'
usage strictement lié à la
capitalisation à la production à la
consommation et à des termes afférents
si vous allez dans la rue vous demandez
aux gens spontanément à quoi il pense qu
on dit économie on va vous parler
d'argent va vous parler de consommation
de production or le mot économie a
existé de manière centrale et continue
d'être utilisée de manière importante
dans toute une série de disciplines qui
vont des sciences de la nature à la
théologie en passant par la
métapsychologie l'esthétique les arts
les mathématiques la logique et j'ai
voulu faire un tour d'horizon dans cette
série de livres qui s'amorce la d usage
du mot économie pour dégager une
synthèse du monde qui nous permet de
nous dégager de la définition
aujourd'hui hégémonique que donnent les
sciences dites économiques du mot de
façon à ce qu'on s'en affranchissent oui
et vous dites il faut reprendre
l'économie aux économistes et disent
aussi l'économie et le capitalisme
oui en fait ce qu'on appelle économie
aujourd'hui renvoie en fait un champ
régional de l'économie l'économie a pu
vouloir dire quelque chose de spécifique
dans les différentes disciplines que
j'ai nommé est ce qu'on appelle
l'économie renvoie en fait plutôt à
l'intendance et de manière plus
spécifique à l'inter
ce capitaliste alors que plus largement
l'économie en ce qui concerne les
affectent en ce qui concerne les
croyances en ce qui concerne les
raisonnements en ce qui concerne
l'organisation sociale renvoie une
compréhension des relations bonnes à une
compréhension des relations escompté
c'est à dire que cette économie toute
réflexion qui porte sur des éléments des
gens des choses que l'on met en relation
en fonction d'un but qu'on juge bon ou
est-ce qu'on monte l'économie
productiviste et consumériste est la
nôtre aujourd'hui et très destructrice
on est face au 21e siècle on est face à
un changement de paradigme annoncé on ne
pourra pas continuer comme ça longtemps
on sait que le pétrole abondant est
relativement abordable est une réalité
qui n'en a que pour quelques décennies
même chose pour les minerais aborde
abordable et abondants on est face à une
crise éco systémique majeur la
biodiversité et et souffre on parle
beaucoup du climat et donc tous ces
facteurs là nous amène à nous dire que
le mot économie comme synonyme du
capitalisme n'a pas lui aussi pour
longtemps dans un changement de mode de
vie un changement d'échelle dans la
façon qu'ont les sociétés de s'organiser
il faudra penser l'économie non pas
comme une façon de satisfaire des
actionnaires des grands actionnaires qui
sont déjà souvent d'opulents plutôt
quatre nés des voeux penser l'économie
en fonction de besoins de dispositions
de talent et de désir sans qu'il soit
question du nerf central du marché ou de
la capitalisation donc de ramener de
rappeler à travers cette critique que
vous faites quand même assez fort du
capitalisme actuel de rappeler qu' il y
à des sensibilités il y à des
interactions entre les écosystèmes en
tout cas dans l'économie de la nature
qui est celui que j'ai lu parce que j'ai
pas du tout votre série mais sur celui
là vous écrivait notamment que le mot
écologie n'aurait
jamais existé si le mot économie n'avait
pas été subtilisés ou vidés de tout son
sens réel au xviiie siècle carl von
linné ou great white et la chose avait
commencé déjà un siècle auparavant parlé
de l'économie de la nature pour désigner
aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle l'écologie
le mot écologie n'existait pas et
l'économie de la nature envoyé à une
analyse des relations entre des espèces
au vu des co système d'un territoire de
climat et d'évolution et encore charles
darwin au 19e ou fairfield osbourne au
xxème siècle utilisé cette expression
recours à cette expression d'économie de
la nature aujourd'hui ces penseurs
surtout les penseurs du xviiie siècle
serait un phare et qu'on désigne comme
étant économique
un régime qui vide les eaux de leurs
poissons qui coupe à blanc des forêts ou
qui exploité surexploite helmand les
seules agraire qu'ils en deviennent
stériles en quelques générations vous
écris donc le mot économie mérite d'être
repensé à londres de cette idée des
relations fécondes à l'un d'eux nous
vous écrivez passé de l'économie de la
nature à l'économisme nous éloigne d'un
rapport sensible aux choses
est ce que vous diriez qu'on a
volontairement séparer l'économie de la
nature parce que la nature en tant que
tel devenait comme une entrave à la
production à la croissance il s'agit pas
d'un complot ou au xviiie siècle à
l'époque où régnait un idéal
rationaliste on a subordonné la nature à
des conceptions très abstraite les
premiers à avoir fait ce sont ceux qui
se sont appelés d'abord évolué les
économistes que la postérité a désigné
comme étant les physiocrates et qui sont
ddd agronome français qui ont voulu
absolument subordonner la terre à des
modèles abstrait en faisant valoir ses
modèles abstrait là comme répondant d'un
idéal naturel de la raison bien
évidemment et aujourd'hui encore les
sciences dites économiques sont tout à
fait séduite par ce type de modélisation
très abstraite et évoluer indépendamment
de réalité vie bien tangible comme l'est
la crise éco systémiques l'annoncent
néanmoins
les lire tout à fait lieu de revenir à
dire une lecture plus sensible des anges
écosystémiques pour en penser l'économie
autrement
l'économie de la nature l'économie de la
fois également il ya d'autres livres
aussi à venir elle est complétée
prochainement cette série où il y aura
un ouvrage s'intitule économe l'économie
esthétique ensuite l'économie psychique
l'économie conceptuel et l'économie
politique ce sera une façon de faire le
tour pour synthétiser sur un mode
conceptuel différence usage du mot
économie pour nous éloigner de cette
façon hégémonique qu'on a aujourd'hui de
penser la chose
merci pour cette réflexion alain
deneault merci de votre écoute